I knew about Teen Wolf before it ever
started so you get the role and I know
MTV I remember I did a show and I mean
guys I'm telling you I got this pilot
for MTV with Jackson Brown's son Ethan
great guy and Leslie Bibb and the three
of us did this show and I was paid four
thousand dollars for the pilot sounds
about right and after taxes and
everything was about for three four
weeks work and I I think I had fourteen
hundred dollars yeah
and then yeah so I know and then they
wanted me to do a development deal
because uh the pilot didn't go but they
liked me we'll give you five grand I'm
like whoa yeah I'm rich that's what I
thought but I mean
were you like was it the same same story
MTV does not they're not known for
paying well but did they start to pay
you in season four and season five I
mean or was it just never a thing about
money with that show they no they were
it was tough always battle